♪ ♪
MICHAEL: Aw, this thing's heavy!
I need some dogs!
I have a new freight sled
that I've never tested
on an overnight trip.
So I'm gonna hook up
a small team, a four-dog team,
and run out to Little Donna Lake
on an overnight camping trip.
It's the trail
that I've never been on.
Usually when dogs
are running new territory,
they're kind of anxious
and nervous.
So this trip is about
teaching them patience,
testing all the equipment,
and pushing them
with a back-to-back run.
(dogs barking)
You know, this early season,
usually you're pretty safe
on a lake.
But I don't know if we'll cross
some swamps or creeks.
Being on a trail
that I've never been on,
it just involves
a little bit more stress,
a little bit more danger,
a little bit more risk.
You don't know where you might
break through the ice.
♪ ♪
(dogs barking)
(howling)
All right, Mao's excited!
Lead dog Mao!
Are you ready to go?
Big bully woolly!
Come on, up-up!
Up-up! Paws!
I'll help you up, buddy.
It's important to mile up
these Alaskan malamutes.
You know, these guys
are my athletes.
They're my workforce.
I have an upcoming
expedition planned,
and I have an upcoming
caribou hunt planned as well.
And that will require
a substantial amount of dogs,
which you gotta
take things in pieces.
You just can't go all out.
Come on.
This is a transition.
You gotta crawl.
You gotta walk.
Then you gotta run.
And this is just the walk phase.
These dogs are as excited
to get on the trail as I am.
♪ ♪
All right!
Time to get out of here.
And hopefully have a good run
with no issues.
♪ ♪
JESSI: As it get's colder,
it's a lot more work out here.
It's a little harder
than I expected.
You have to work for everything
you get out here.
♪ ♪
So, I got the pick,
the shovel, and the crates.
Time to go!
Water's a resource out here,
just like our wood
and our food is.
So, we're constantly having
to battle to get more water.
Even though the river's
right next to the house, uh,
it's still kind of a chore,
and Chris clears all the snow
with the shovel,
and then he's gotta use the axe
to chip just the clear ice
away from the river.
This is, hands down,
the best way
to get drinking water
for the house.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: I am going to go down
to start shoveling.
Wow, that's slick!
Every day we feel like
we're dehydrated
and we're fighting
to keep up with water.
If you don't have enough water,
you're gonna die.
Here's one piece of clear ice.
Look at that.
This clear ice, once you
melt it down and filter it out,
this is some of
the best-tasting water
that I've ever had out here.
♪ ♪
This ice is opaque.
I want that clear stuff.
I'm just after drinking water.
As you can see here,
this ice is really clear.
But as we start to get
down farther to the river,
it starts to darken.
And the darker it is, you know,
the more swamp is in it,
the more grass is in it.
It even dyes your urine
different colors.
So from here to here,
this like two-foot section
is where we come and harvest
our drinking ice.
♪ ♪
JESSI: We've kind of got it
down pat.
He gets some really big chunks,
and we bring that into the house
and have to break that down.
But he also gets smaller chunks
that he hucks up the bank
and hopefully
into my waiting arms,
to put into the crate.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: How full are we?
JESSI: I'd say that's good.
CHRIS: Okay.
JESSI: We've got
all these big pieces,
plus these three crates
are all filled.
CHRIS: Nice!
JESSI: It's a good water haul.
CHRIS: Come back tomorrow
and keep moving forward.
♪ ♪
BRENT:
You just can't survive here
unless you're 150% into it
and willing to put
all the blood, sweat,
and tears it takes.
You have to have that passion
in order to be able to survive
and make it out here.
♪ ♪
Hey! Marble!
Come on! Come here!
Come here, you little butthead!
Okay!
See?
This is what the problem is.
You just like to break out
all the time, don't you?
We're gonna solve
that problem right now.
We're just back
from a good training run
and Ida's in town taking care
of some business there.
So I've got some time to work
on a few projects
around the homestead here
for the next couple of days.
Today's biggest and
most important project
is fixing the puppy pen.
We've got nine puppies.
They're all around
three months old.
Now, because of all the snow,
their pen's fence
has gotten really low.
And so, they can jump right over
and they're jumping out
and causing problems.
This is the real problem area,
this section right here.
We're gonna need to, uh,
build that fence up higher
and then dig that last section
all the way down to the ground.
So, yeah, this is
super important
and we're gonna, we're gonna
get 'er done today.
And then hopefully you guys will
stay in this pen, huh?
This is totally
making it up as I go,
but I'm gonna try and get this
rope woven through this fence.
So, having this pen like this
and having the dogs
be able to be loose
when they're this age
is super important.
For their socialization
and for their happiness,
they need to be free,
running around.
So, this is really important
because of that.
We can't have them breaking out.
♪ ♪
(chuckles)
Didn't say it
was gonna be pretty.
The lifestyle here livin' on
at the homestead,
it's a life full of work.
Out here, the boss
is Mother Nature.
The boss is the homestead
and the dogs.
And they're dictating
what I've gotta do every day
and what's a higher priority.
But that freedom to be able
to live out here
with my 50 and 60 dogs
is well worth all the chores
and the extra work.
For me, it's my paradise.
I wouldn't trade this lifestyle
for anything.
♪ ♪
Our snow level was here,
and the fence was here.
So, we only had a couple feet,
now we've almost eight,
nine feet of, uh, clearance
on the fence.
And I think it's gonna keep
these puppies from breaking out.
Huh, guys?
Time to move on
to the next chore tomorrow.
Get some snow shoveled
off the roofs.
But I'm hopefully gonna wake up
to puppies in the pen
tomorrow morning.
♪ ♪
ALEX: I don't think
in my mind, like,
"Oh, this will be,
this will be easy."
It's better to just, you know,
be open to whatever's
gonna happen.
♪ ♪
Sipsy. You ready?
Today, I'm really
thinking ahead,
I'm thinking about springtime
when breakup comes.
♪ ♪
NARRATOR: For Alex Javor,
staying ahead of the season
is key to surviving
his lifestyle.
With rising river waters
and spring on the horizon,
he'll need to replace
an old shift bridge
in order to keep an escape path
to civilization.
♪ ♪
ALEX: So, when the creek runs,
like a small river,
it's got
a really strong current.
You know, you'll see big trees
blasting down through the creek.
It's, uh, kind of
a serious force of nature
you gotta contend with.
If I got hurt or I need
to move fast,
the bridge is just a, uh,
a lifeline
if you have an emergency.
How do I get across this thing
without freezing,
without getting
all my stuff wet?
You know, you can do it,
but it's a big thing
you gotta deal with.
You know, if you had
a bad situation,
it could turn things
into a much worse situation.
♪ ♪
(groans)
Uh, right where I'm standing,
the old bridge
used to go across here.
I think this is part,
I think this is from
the original bridge.
There was two big trees
that went across
and then a bunch of planks
that spanned them.
It washed away some point
after I had left here.
Uh, you can see
this is what's happened.
♪ ♪
ALEX: It's not water,
it's, uh, overflow ice
from when the creek ran.
Puttin' the bridge here because,
basically, this is possible.
It's tall enough
it won't flood.
And then we got the bank over
here with lots of big trees.
So, what I got in mind
is dead simple,
just make the tree fall across.
And that's it.
If you have trouble balancing,
you can kind of sit and scoot,
or we could put up a rope,
you know,
to help, to handhold onto.
So, I'm just kind of, uh,
check out my trees here
and try to figure out
which one, uh, would be best.
I think this one might be good.
The only good candidate
is this big one.
It'll definitely go across,
all the way.
I think at least one
I'll need to cut down.
If the tree breaks
the wrong way,
I want to kind of have
a clear path.
That's it.
Got my plan, so uh, you know,
it's just time to get to work.
Make my bridge.
Nothing to it but to do it.
♪ ♪
MICHAEL:
I worry about bad snowdrifts
that set up like concrete.
And threaten to throw
you and your sled
off into no-man's-land.
There's a lot of anxiety
built up with a trip like this.
♪ ♪
(dogs howling)
Calm down!
All right!
Gonna have a night ride here.
This ought to be interesting.
NARRATOR:
After traveling 60 miles
for a training run
and overnight camping trip,
Michael Manzo
is preparing his dogs
for a challenging journey
to Little Donna Lake.
With no time to waste,
he must traverse
this uncharted trail
in complete darkness.
MICHAEL: You know people,
because of climate change,
are breaking through the ice
at times
where they're normally used to
traveling and subsisting.
Last year, there was
a tragic loss
of about three lives
in one event.
So out there on the trails,
you have to keep your head
in the game.
♪ ♪
Hooking up on a new trail for
the first time, it's stressful.
But you gotta get
out of your comfort zone
to refine and get better.
All right, this is
the last dog to hook up.
Time to hit that open trail.
Hyah, hyah, hyah, hyah!
Here we go! Here we go!
Holy smokes, you guys
are full of it today!
Absolutely full of it!
All right!
Sled's handling good.
The trail's a little bumpy
and inconsistent.
But I'm actually able to get
this thing sitting upright.
The dogs are really hoofing it.
They look good.
I really love being
out on the trail.
It lifts my spirit.
The dogs can sense
that I'm happy.
Good turn! Good boys!
I would not be able
to live like this
if I was working that typical
dead-end job in the city.
It takes years to learn a lot
of this stuff on your own:
How to build dog sleds.
How to tie up lines.
How to live off the land.
And you know, when you're
working for the man,
you barely have enough time
to scratch your own butt.
We're taking this trail
with steam.
Whoa!
Good boys.
All right.
I made it five miles.
I'm at Donna Lake,
the dogs did great.
Sled handled well.
Everybody got here
safe and sound.
It's time to give some water,
and then get a meal
into these dogs.
They've never been
on this trail before.
Now it's time to set up my camp
and get some rest.
It's been a hard run.
♪ ♪
BRENT:
You can't predict the weather,
force Mother Nature, so you're
just rolling with the punches.
♪ ♪
Hi, guys!
All right.
Well, now that these guys
are all locked in
the pen again, huh?
Today's project is, uh,
getting up on this roof.
This snow's been piling up
for a long time now.
Ida's out of town.
It's the perfect time
to just get this project done.
This stuff right here is a bad
deal because it jams up here,
and then when the building
warms up a little bit,
it can leak, uh, into the cabin.
Snow is like
a double-edged sword.
We really want it, we love it,
I'm smiling every time
it comes down.
But then, after a certain point
of snow, you're kind of like,
"Okay, it can slow down now,"
because every time it snows,
it adds more chores to our list.
Got most of this glacier
off here.
I'm gonna grab
that ladder down there.
Francis! No chewing on it!
And put it on this roof,
and then climb up onto the peak.
Francis!
No! No chewing!
I'm gonna take
your chew toy away.
I've spent a lot of time
up high on roofs.
I've only fallen
off a couple of times.
But, uh, out here, safety
is like our number one thing.
This is a higher roof than most
of them here at the property.
It's also steeper.
If you fall off the roof,
it could be
a life-or-death situation.
I just have to have a good hold.
Because if I get up on that,
on the top of the ladder
and it starts to slide,
I could slide off the roof.
Like I almost did right there.
That edge is a little closer
than I thought.
♪ ♪
Wow, look at that! Progress!
I would much rather be
running dogs right now,
but this is just one of
those necessities, you know?
It's one of those hundreds
of chores that we have to do
to keep the homestead
and keep everything maintained.
'Cause if I don't do this,
it's gonna take me more time
down the road.
♪ ♪
All right, well, we wrapped
this project up here.
All the snow is off.
Thousands of pounds
of snow off the roof.
And we still got some daylight,
so, one project down,
millions of projects to go.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: Getting accomplished
is what is really awesome
about being out here.
So sometimes you just have to
forget the aches and pains
and push through.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: I'd like to cut
right about here.
Close to the bank,
close to the river.
Then, we'll go get the pumps
and we'll drop 'em in the water
and get some water
up to the house.
(chainsaw starts)
NARRATOR: Living remotely,
it's critical
for Chris and Jessi
to secure water,
not only for drinking,
but for cooking and cleaning.
Today they will install
a water pump system
in the hopes of storing
more bottled water
for the months ahead.
CHRIS: Uh, metal shovel?
JESSI: You want the Pulaski
or the shovel?
CHRIS: Let me see
that Pulaski first.
I think that's gonna do
some damage.
JESSI: ♪ Hi-ho! Hi-ho! ♪
Looks like that was made
for getting ice.
CHRIS: It's getting wet
down here.
I'm gonna start
chipping off the sides now.
♪ ♪
Water's one of the most
frustrating things
to get out here.
We need it every day.
Chipping ice, that's great
for drinking water.
But we can't do that for washing
laundry and doing dishes.
That requires a lot of water,
so we're always trying
to come up with new ways.
So we got
our nice clear ice here.
And this is the beginning
of the overflow.
And you see it's not very clear
and it's very yellow.
It's the kind of dirty water
we're trying to get away from.
It's damp down there,
so we're gonna pop through.
There it is. We got water.
JESSI: Nice!
CHRIS: And hopefully, it just
fills right up to the top.
JESSI: Oh, okay.
It's cracking! It's cracking!
CHRIS: It's just 'cause
it's relieving pressure,
it's no problem.
JESSI: It's cracking on the edge
and I don't want to be on it!
CHRIS: Perfect.
JESSI: Nope, nope! Nope, nope!
CHRIS: You know, there's always
a danger involved
when you're doing stuff.
If you break through
the shelf ice
and there's water underneath it,
you're going in.
Well, we got
a perfect hole, love.
JESSI: I'm sorry, I didn't
want to be over there
if it's cracking.
CHRIS: Just trust
in your husband.
(Jessi laughs)
It's excellent,
we finally got water.
Again, this isn't
drinking water.
This is kind of like
our utility water.
It's kind of murky
and a little dingy,
but it does great for dishes
and, uh, clothes
and bath houses
and all sorts of stuff.
We're hoping to get at least
a month's worth of water,
so getting a lot of water
like this up to the cabin
is gonna be excellent.
JESSI: All right, so you
just need to go get
the pumps and the hose?
CHRIS: All at once,
we're gonna bring out the hoses
and the pumps
in a straight line.
I'm gonna get the pump into here
and get the hoses all connected.
JESSI: Before it freezes?
CHRIS: And then we'll
start plugging 'em in, yeah.
♪ ♪
Never used the pumps before.
Uh, they're kind of like
a sump pump.
We used to use them
for showers and such,
but, uh, we're gonna try and see
if we can pump some water
up the bank.
♪ ♪
See if we can get some water,
there it goes!
JESSI: Hey, that's clear water.
How's it feel?
Doesn't feel
like it's warming up?
CHRIS:
Yeah, it seems slower now.
I'm gonna go down
and check the end.
JESSI: Huh.
CHRIS: Is that any better?
JESSI: Seemed like it was
a lot better in the beginning.
CHRIS: It's probably
just getting ice
sucked up or something.
JESSI: It's like a third
of what it was.
Now there's nothing.
We got zero water!
JESSI: We got zero water!
CHRIS: Maybe we're just
too high up.
JESSI: It worked well
right at the beginning.
CHRIS: It must have froze.
JESSI: The actual pump itself?
CHRIS: No, it's, the pump
is still pumping,
I bet the line somewhere.
It's going through the snow
and it's cold out.
I'm gonna go down
and see if there's, uh,
some air in the line
or something.
I'm gonna see if I can get it
to pump harder down there.
JESSI: There's got to be
a bit of ice in the line.
'Cause nothing's coming out,
and the pump's right next
to the end of the hose.
You want to use that red hose
instead of the white hose?
CHRIS: Yeah, toss it down.
Damn! Always something.
JESSI: One of these days,
we'll figure it out;
what we need to get water.
CHRIS: Hold that end.
♪ ♪
JESSI: Uh, I'm gonna
get up there.
I'll need you to kind of
toss this to me.
CHRIS: Okay. Hand it back.
Once you get back up,
just plug me in.
JESSI: And I'm plugging in!
CHRIS: I see water going!
JESSI: Yup, yup, yup!
CHRIS: All right!
How's it coming out?
Pretty quick?
JESSI: It's like when you turn
your tap water on,
it's like, uh, one third.
CHRIS: All right, I'm coming up!
That's going pretty quick.
JESSI: Yeah, I'm not sure
it's any faster
than us just dipping
our buckets in,
but my back is thankful.
CHRIS: Yeah, I'm not
slipping and falling
and pouring water
all over myself.
JESSI: All right,
you wanna take that one?
CHRIS: I'll swap you out.
I'll just bring this
right over to you.
I thought this pump was going to
be the answer to our problems.
Doesn't seem to be.
But it's still easier
than hauling buckets
full of water up the hill.
So, frustrating as it is,
it seems to be the best solution
we have right now.
This worked today,
but I don't think it's gonna
work once it gets colder.
♪ ♪
ALEX: If I don't want
to do something,
I just, I'm not doing it.
But if I do want to do
something, you know,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna do it
as best as I can.
(chopping)
♪ ♪
There we go.
(chuckles)
Well, there's one.
Now, we got the big guy.
It's gonna be a lot of chopping.
NARRATOR: For Alex, having
a bridge across the river
will ensure an emergency escape
route once the water rises.
With one piece
of the bridge secured,
he'll need to carefully fall
a main massive tree
in just the right place.
ALEX: Yeah, I got my, uh,
my rope and pulley set up,
with this, you know, extra
bit of tension on the tree,
that's gonna help guide it
to fall this way to towards me,
versus wanting to go
some other way.
This is like
a super massive tree,
so I gotta be really careful.
These ropes all have
kind of a maximum amount
of weight they can hold.
If I put a thousand pounds
of pressure on it,
the rope will probably break,
and people do sometimes
get killed, um, from snap-back.
Time to, time to get to work.
♪ ♪
This will be the biggest tree
I've ever cut down.
That doesn't really
make me excited.
To be honest,
it kind of makes me feel
like I'm gonna feel relief
once it's over.
You know, I like
pushing the limits,
but not really
with stuff like this.
It's like, uh, teasing forces
that could easily crush me.
♪ ♪
It's making noises!
(cracking)
♪ ♪
Wow, now, that was something.
Pretty awesome to witness.
But it did do
what I didn't want it to do,
it popped down a bit.
And, uh, once
the creek water comes,
it would probably grab it
and take it away.
So I want to, I want to pull it
back up on shore a bit.
First thing tomorrow,
I'll come back out here
and finish this out strong.
♪ ♪
MICHAEL:
There's a lot of unknowns
when you're in new territory.
And you can never guarantee
that you're gonna
make it home safely.
That's what I struggle with,
is the anxiety of the unknown.
♪ ♪
All right, camp is broke down.
You know, this is all about
a training run for the dogs,
but if I could sneak in a little
bit of fishing, I'm a happy man.
So, I'm gonna try my hand
at fishing this lake.
Maybe I might catch
a char or a trout.
So, this is just jigging,
and this is my ice-fishing pole.
You don't really use
a long pole,
usually, you can use a stick
and you send a lure or some bait
down in the hole.
And every so often,
you just move it a little bit.
The fish are sluggish
in the winter.
So, you gotta just wait it out
and take your time.
Just like it takes patience
with the dogs,
ice fishing takes patience, too.
Sometimes you come away
with a bunch of fish,
sometimes you don't
catch nothing.
So, we had a great run-in
to this beautiful campsite,
and now we got all this ice fog
sitting here.
It's kind of
a majestic landscape.
This is kind of like
my vacation time,
and I honestly don't get
to fish much.
You know, I'm busy
catching moose,
busy catching winter caribou.
I only probably get about
a couple of fishing trips
in a year.
And if I can get a fish,
that'd be a real nice treat.
All right, I've been going at it
for a few minutes,
haven't got any bites.
But I'm running out of daylight.
As much as I'd like to put
more focus on this lake,
drilling holes here and there,
trying to locate the fish...
Ooh!
MICHAEL: Ooh! There we go.
Got a big one.
Just as I was thinking
about packing up,
I finally hit a fish.
That's a beautiful trout.
That'll go good
in the frying pan.
It's such a tease, because
where there's one, there's more,
but I'm about ready to leave
out of here and pack up,
'cause the ice fog is coming in
and the visibility is reducing.
I think there may be
a storm coming.
So it's time to transition.
This is a bonus of the trip,
catching a nice fish like that.
But unfortunately, we gotta get
these dogs out of here
before this storm comes in,
get home safely and
call this a successful run.
♪ ♪
Whoo! Go get 'em! Go get 'em!
Hyah-hyah-hyah!
There we go! There we go!
The dogs, I've been running them
for a half a decade.
And I get better
and the dogs get better
as the years progress.
These malamutes,
they're not machines.
They are living beings.
They have emotions
of excitement,
emotions of nervousness.
It's quite a challenge.
And this run is
to really get dialed in
so that come expedition time,
or come caribou hunt,
we're ready for it.
I would call this trip
a success.
♪ ♪
BRENT: My to-do list
only gets bigger.
It doesn't shrink,
it never goes away.
It'll never, you'll never
catch up. (laughs)
♪ ♪
Up the mountain we go.
See how long my stuff
lasts in the sled.
I just finished up getting
all the snow off the roof.
So that's a big project
checked off the list.
We still have some light
in the day,
so we're gonna head up
to check out my comms.
It's, we have
our satellite Internet.
It frequently gets blown in
and snow can get into the box
where the modem is,
so we gotta check that out.
We don't have a very
conventional Internet setup.
We get the signal
from the satellite dish,
it goes down into a cooler
that's up there
where the modem sits.
That sends the signal
to this bridge.
From there, it goes
into this CAT 5 wire,
that goes down to this PVC pipe
that goes down through the trees
across the trail
and down to the shop,
which is another 400 feet
down there.
There's a lot
of bush engineering,
is what we call it.
So we're going up there
to check this system out
to make sure the modem's
not buried in snow.
Something we got to do it
all the time,
'cause it's our only source
of communication
with the real world.
All right, well, right here you
can see the wind and the snow
has totally buried
that Igloo cooler.
Out here you have to play
all the roles,
and here you gotta play
the cable guy.
You know, you just can't call
somebody to come and fix this.
Living remote
like we do out here,
it's super important to have
a really solid line
of communication.
We're 150 miles
down a mostly gravel road
that has very unpredictable
weather conditions
throughout most of the year,
especially in the wintertime.
And so our lifeline
is the satellite Internet.
It connects us enough
so that if we get in trouble,
we can reach out
and get that help.
Moment of truth here.
We'll see what everything
looks like inside.
Unbelievably, it looks
pretty darn good.
It's pretty amazing,
this modem here is, uh, warm.
And the cables are all warm,
the outlet, everything
is warm and dry.
Everything is operational.
Success.
The check-up is good.
Ida comes back tonight.
Quick trip home, and have
a good day in the books.
♪ ♪
JESSI: I'm just
pushing myself more.
Because in the past,
I haven't pushed myself,
and I haven't succeeded,
and it stinking sucks.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: All right!
You ready to cut
some blocks of ice?
Do you want to get
your small chainsaw
and cut me a black spruce?
NARRATOR: After getting a small
amount of water for drinking
and a failed attempt
at a pump system,
Chris and Jessi
are going to try
a traditional yet extremely
dangerous way of getting water:
pulling large chunks of ice
directly from a frozen river.
CHRIS: My dad used to come out
to the river and harvest ice.
I've never done it,
and I want to try and learn.
Figure I take advantage
of the warm weather,
add to our stockpile of water.
We need it every day,
and it's hard to get.
If it gets any colder out here,
then it's gonna be a lot harder.
I need to get as much
as possible right now.
This is not free yet.
Oh, there it goes. Okay.
JESSI: Nice!
CHRIS: You got
that small chainsaw?
(starts chainsaw)
(buzzing)
♪ ♪
See if I can get this
through the hole.
Okay. Something to poke it
through with.
All right.
I'm just gonna have to hit it
hard with the snow machine.
Let's see what happens, huh?
Hopefully,
we don't bust a stick.
(engine starts)
All right!
JESSI: Whoa!
CHRIS: What happened?
JESSI: It got pulled
and snapped.
What do you think about me,
like, levering from the back?
CHRIS: Yeah.
JESSI: I just need
something that's bigger
than this little stick
that I have.
CHRIS: Wow, that's big!
That thing probably
weighs 300 pounds.
Hopefully we can get it out.
That's a big chunk of ice
to bring home.
I'm gonna pick up on this rope
and I'm gonna have you
stick the fat end down.
JESSI: Okay.
CHRIS: If possible.
JESSI: I'm trying.
CHRIS: You're doing great.
JESSI: I'm beginning to hate
getting water.
CHRIS: What's that?
JESSI: Nothing!
CHRIS: I forget
that Jessi doesn't have
the strength that I have.
Yeah, I thought this was
gonna be easier.
JESSI: No kidding.
CHRIS:
She's working really hard,
she's doing the best she can.
JESSI: I can't lever any more.
CHRIS: Okay.
We definitely work really well
as a team together.
And as far as partners go,
she's kicking ass out here.
JESSI: You got this, love,
don't worry.
♪ ♪
CHRIS: Holy cow!
JESSI: Yeah.
CHRIS: That is
a huge block of ice.
JESSI: Oh, you're gonna
get soaked, my love.
CHRIS: Okay. I'm gonna try
to pick it up again.
(struggling)
Let's see if I can get it out.
(grunts)
JESSI: What are you
trying to do?
Are you trying to get it
out of the hole?
CHRIS: Yeah.
JESSI: Just by your back power?
CHRIS: Yeah, maybe just
stick the stick there
and come help me.
I can almost get it out.
I just don't have enough oomph
to get it over the edge.
One, two and up!
♪ ♪
CHRIS: Oh, don't let it,
you're holding me down!
You're holding me down!
All this weight is on me.
Move the rope!
Let it go! Jeez!
JESSI: All right.
CHRIS: I am so soaked!
Let's try to get it up and out.
There it is!
Holy (bleep)!
I'm trying to get that
under the side.
JESSI: Okay.
CHRIS: I think this thing's
too big to come out.
JESSI: I have a, I'm scared
of going in the hole.
CHRIS: Don't go in the hole.
JESSI: Well...
CHRIS: You won't come back up.
Rock it.
Okay.
JESSI: When you pull it up,
it pulls right out of my hands.
CHRIS: Then you pull it up.
I just--You're not able
to pull it very hard.
Okay.
There it is.
Go winch the winch!
JESSI: Okay, got it?
CHRIS: Yeah.
♪ ♪
You got it, love!
Good work!
One, two, and up!
We got it, love!
Ho!
(starts chainsaw)
All right!
I'm gonna cut this block up in
half and see if we can move it.
(revving chainsaw)
(buzzing)
JESSI: Nice!
CHRIS: I'll go get the sled,
we'll pull the sled around,
and we'll try to work it
in there, huh?
JESSI: This is the first year
that we've even harvested ice.
You know, those chunks
in front of the house
that we got out of the river.
That was--I thought those
were big chunks, you know?
But, dang.
Uh, this is a bit bigger
of a chore
than I was anticipating today.
CHRIS: One, two, and up!
JESSI: Holy crap!
CHRIS: Come on!
There's one.
One, two, over!
(grunting)
JESSI: You're so strong, Chris.
CHRIS: I got it.
Okay.
JESSI: Yeah!
CHRIS: I'm just gonna go home,
and I'll come back for you
if I can get it to move.
You ready?
JESSI: Go, go, go, go, go, go!
If we do this again,
it's gotta be smaller pieces.
That was like right on the cusp
of just not being able
to do it at all
under Chris and I's power.
(snow machine roaring)
♪ ♪
ALEX: I think that any time
you take on a challenge
and you see it through
to the end,
it's gonna be, uh, you know,
a big positive growth.
♪ ♪
Hey, Sipsy.
Checking things out?
I got the tree down.
The next big problem I have is,
uh, the base of the tree.
You know, I was hoping it
would have stayed right here,
but it popped out, uh,
which, you know,
could make it really susceptible
to, uh, getting, you know,
washed away in the creek.
'Cause this shore,
every time the water
comes through each spring,
it recedes by a foot or so.
So, if I can get it, you know,
up here a good ways,
the bridge will last
for a while.
So, the first thing I'm gonna do
is put in some smaller logs
underneath
to kind of act as skid logs
to help guide the log
up to where I want it.
So, you just give it a surface
that it's gonna glide over
more easily than pulling it
on the ground.
I got my skid log,
so that should help it
just kind of glide
up into place.
I'll go across and, uh, cut off
the excess part of the tree
to make it lighter.
That'll make it
a little easier to pull.
Think I might cut it
right in here.
It should be good.
♪ ♪
I'm not religious, but, um,
I feel like there's a right way
for humans to live,
and then there's a wrong way.
Everything we already need
is already here, in nature.
If you don't appreciate that,
I think you're giving a big
middle finger to Mother Nature
because, uh, no matter what,
you live within and under
Mother Nature's rule.
For humans to survive
indefinitely,
we'll have to learn how to live
by appreciating
what the Earth gives
and not abusing it.
That's good.
(exhales)
Let's, uh, give her a pull.
If everything goes good,
it should just kind of glide
right up these logs,
and that'd be it.
Let's do it.
(grunting)
(bleep) thing's
not working right.
That cheap piece of (bleep).
Come on.
Not a lot of things
get me frustrated,
but one thing that gets me
frustrated pretty quick
is, uh, cheap gear.
When I get frustrated,
I tend to cuss and throw stuff.
Thing's all (bleep) up.
If I just kind of
let myself do that,
then I don't carry
any frustration with me
for the rest of the day,
you know,
let my angry, inner primate
out when I need to.
Keeps me from drinking.
Oh!
There she went!
Pulling good now.
Slow and steady.
Just one notch at a time.
♪ ♪
Agh! (bleep)
Piece of (bleep).
ALEX: Agh! (bleep)
I guess it got enough weight,
it broke the, uh, skid logs
underneath it.
It's on the shore,
but just barely.
That digging into the ground
is going to make it
really hard to pull.
Probably I can, uh, pull 'em
from the middle,
somewhere in here.
If I can scoot it over
just a couple feet, uh,
laterally, you know,
to the side.
That should allow the end
of the log to travel free
without digging into the snow
and getting stuck.
This tree, because it's so
massive and it weighs so much,
my options for moving it
are really limited.
With this two-ton pulley, I'm
able to slowly, inch by inch,
kind of drag it
a little bit this way.
And that's about it.
When you're working alone
on a project like this,
you'll either become patient
or you'll have to quit.
As they say in the Army,
"Slow is smooth
and smooth is fast."
♪ ♪
Okay.
Well, that's that.
I felt a relief
to have this done.
That was pretty difficult.
I mean, you could see moving
this much weight, you know,
five feet, ten feet,
I mean, it's taken,
like, a lot of work.
So, now that I've got the tree
where I want it,
I'm gonna collect whatever
scrap lumber I got
and just basically piece
together a flat walking surface.
♪ ♪
Whenever I do something,
I tend to go into it 110%.
I'm either doing it
all the way or not.
I guess at the end of the day,
we all just want to feel good.
The satisfaction I get from
taking on a tough challenge,
working hard,
facing the natural challenges
Mother Nature gives you
here in Alaska,
I find that to be
more satisfying
than living an easy,
decadent life in the city.
I approve of this bridge.
It's gonna work for me,
but, uh, I think I gotta
get the inspector
to get the, uh, final approval.
Atta boy, there you go.
Aw, Sipsy, I'm so proud of you.
Bridge is done.
I'm pretty happy with it.
In case of an emergency,
I'll still be able
to get across the creek.
Sipsy gave his seal of approval.
This spring, when the creek
is running,
Sipsy will, uh, happily run
back and forth across
so he can chase the squirrels
wherever they go.
♪ Fed to the wolves
without retreat ♪
♪ Mm mm mm mmm ♪
JESSI: Can you get me
just a little bit more,
uh, hot water, please?
CHRIS: Yeah.
Give me just a second.
♪ ♪
JESSI: We're lucky if we get
a bath once a week out here.
It just takes a lot of water.
I don't know if it's any harder
out here this year.
I just, I am more willing?
I'm just pushing myself more.
As long as you have
a good, optimistic, you know,
feeling in your body, and you're
just happy to be here,
no matter how hard
the work gets,
you're gonna get it done.
♪ You got the devil
inside you ♪
♪ You set the church
on fire ♪
♪ ♪
BRENT: There she is!
You made it!
IDA: I made it, yeah,
it's nice to be back.
Wow, look at that roof!
BRENT: Yep, got some snow off,
got all the glaciers off.
I'm sure you're cold
from your trip.
We should head inside
with some wood.
IDA: Home sweet home.
♪ Day of rust
and nights of rain ♪
I can tell that you've been busy
with all of these little things
that we've had on the list
for a while.
BRENT: Yeah, yeah, it's been
a really productive
couple of days.
So, we'll just keep
whittling away at it.
Three chores down,
six more added.
IDA: Yeah.
That's part of the life.
BRENT: That's the nature
of the game,
but for now,
let's enjoy our fire
and get a good night's sleep
and start it up tomorrow.
IDA: Yeah, it's really good
to be back home.
BRENT: He's happy you're back.
IDA: I always have time
for the pets.
♪ You got, you got the devil
inside you ♪
♪ You set the church on fire ♪
♪ You got, you got the devil
inside you ♪
MICHAEL: Dogs are all fed,
settled in their houses,
sleeping like babies.
I'm gonna go ahead
and enjoy myself a nice meal
after a hard training run.
You know, the focus of that trip
was to train the dogs
in a new environment.
Now that they've done
back-to-back five-mile runs
with a camping trip, it's time
to increase that mileage.
These dogs are
getting to the point
where it's time to get
on the trail
and go on an expedition
or hunt caribou.
So here we got a nice
pan-fried rainbow trout
right on the wood stove.
This is, uh, just
icing on the cake
after a fun run with the dogs.
This is my way of life.
You know, these dogs are
an extension of my vision
of having the most authentic
Alaskan lifestyle
that I can live.
They're my athletes, they're
my hunting and fishing buddies.
And I could never picture living
in Alaska without sled dogs.
You know, if I ever got rid
of these dogs,
there'd probably be
an empty void in my heart.
Together as a team, we'll
continue on and do great things.
♪ You got the devil
inside you ♪
♪ The devil inside you ♪